We're trying to study political
correctness and so what the first thing
we're trying to figure out was is there
even such a thing?
Because if you,
if you look at the political dialogue,
what you find is that people on the side
of the political spectrum who have been
defined as politically correct tend to
say that it doesn't exist and that that
category is just a pejorative term that
was invented by people who hold
alternative political opinions.
And so the first question is,
well,
what do you mean some does it exist?
What do you mean by exist?
What?
How do you tell if a psychological
concept is real?
Like his anger is anger or something
that exists objectively.
Is it done an objective phenomena?
Well,
it's not that easy to determine.
You say,
well,
we,
we act like it is and we understand what
anger means,
but no one goes along round in the world
and says anger without saying anything
else or you'd run away from them.
You know,
what they do is they,
they,
they placed the word anger into a
sentence and place the sentence within a
conversation and they enable you to
infer exactly what they mean by the word
anger,
by listening to the surrounding context.
Right?
And,
and if you're going to turn that into
something like an objective term,
what you do is you pull out the term
anger and then you make the hypothesis
that it represents something real in the
objective world,
but it's not that easy to determine if
something does exist,
especially if it's a psychological
phenomena in the real world.
What do you mean by exist?
That's the problem of construct
validation.
Okay,
so that's another term you really need
to know if you're interested in
experimental psychology,
especially on the personality and a
construct is a representation of
something psychological that
hypothetically exists.
Objectively,
how do you establish its existence
objectively?
Well?
Does fear exist?
No.
Does you have the problem with all the
emotional terms?
Does joy exist to surprise exist?
Does embarrassment exist?
Does guilt exist?
Shame?
How are they related to one another?
Guilt and shame,
for example,
seem quite similar to one another,
right,
and pain and fear and anger all seem to
share the,
the,
the attribute of unpleasant to negative
emotions and so how similar,
how something,
if something exists,
it should be the same as some things and
different from other things and that's
part of construct validation as well to
specify how the construct is the same as
some things and different from others.
Anger should be reliably distinguishable
from joy,
for example,
because otherwise they're not different
and anger and fear should be somewhat
the same if they're both negative
emotions.
So it's extraordinarily complex to,
to,
to validate a construct.
And so here,
here's what we did with political
correctness.
It's,
and it's.
The reason I'm using the political
examples is because that's an obvious
place where self serving bias can enter
the scientific arena.
Right?
So if I wanted to make a point about
political correctness or if I wanted to
make a point about right wing fascism,
I could build my biases into the
measurement instruments accidentally and
then they would produce as output what I
put into them as input.
And I want to protect myself against
that if I actually want to do this
scientific investigation properly.
So what we did when we started to
construct our measures of political
correctness was employ a number of
people to go through as many news
sources as they could get their hands on
to identify any attitude or behavior,
some roughly that that had been
described by anyone at all as
potentially politically correct.
So it was kind of agnostic and we're
trying to do it as randomly as possible,
you know,
to get as many new sources as we
possibly could so that we were sampling
across the environment without bias.
Okay.
So then we came up with,
I don't remember how many,
couple hundred,
maybe more a couple hundred items that
were roughly indicative of what you
might describe as political correctness,
but that's not good enough,
right?
Because just because you have this
random assemblage of items doesn't
indicate at all that they're all
measuring something that was similar,
but that's just implicit.
They're all cold political correctness,
but you don't know if those attitudes
covariate.
And what that means is if you held one
attitude of that list,
were you more likely to hold another or
multiple others?
Right?
So is the conditional probability of
holding multiple items?
Is there a high probability of holding
true multiple items simultaneously while
you figure that out with factor
analysis?
So what we did is we turned that into a
questionnaire using different question
types and we administered it to several
hundred people and we did a factor
analysis and we found actually that
there was such a thing as political
correctness because the questions
clumped together,
people would reliably answered them in a
pattern manner,
but that there were actually two
dimensions that were quite separate.
So there isn't one political
correctness.
There seems to be two.
And then we looked at the personality
predictors in the ICU predictors and a
variety of other predictors that would
enable us to come to some understanding
of the temperamental proclivity towards
those political attitudes,
if any.
We knew already that political
conservatives tended to be low in trade,
openness.
That's the creativity dimension and high
in trait conscientiousness.
Whereas political liberals tended to be
high in trait,
openness and low in conscientiousness,
and so one of the things that's
extraordinarily interesting to know from
the big five perspective is that your
political proclivities are very
powerfully influenced by your
temperament.
And so one of the things you can think
about with regards to ongoing political
discussions in the real world is that
those discussions are actually attempts
by people of different temperaments.
One,
to impose their temperamental viewpoints
on the world and to,
to engage in a dialogue with people who
are actually quite different than they
are.